When I look at this graph, one of my takeaways is just sort of,
just looking at the, the slopes and
I can see that, you know, five of the seven categories are doing really well.
And so, the team's doing really well in those.
>> Yeah. >> Compared to the company, let's say overall.
But, for two of them.
Looks like management and career development not so much.
so, I think it's really interesting how you mention that there's so
few data points, yet the rankings are there and it's really easy to see sort of
like how the team is doing in comparison to the company.
>> Yeah, there's actually a whole lot of information.
>> Yeah. >> In a relatively straightforward manner.
>> Yeah.